In examples in previous lessons we have introduced to you
various ways of building models.
We investigated applicability and merits of the various models and
went through some of the steps of questioning and validation.
Iterating between these steps towards building the models.
In this lesson, we will take a deeper dive into the model validation process.
Before getting into this, let us think of a situation where we
want to teach a six year old how to multiply two numbers.
To do so, we show her how to multiply by using many pairs of numbers.
Let's say we use 100 pairs of numbers.
After a while we are convinced that she can multiply two numbers and
want to test her skill.
Now if we test her multiplication skills on the same numbers that we gave her
to learn multiplication with there is always the possibility that she
did not figure out the underlying algorithms or
patterns for multiplying, but has simply memorized all the values.
A good test will be to ask her to multiply numbers she has not seen before.
We want to test how well she learned by giving her
data which she has never seen before.
A similar approach is required in testing models.
How well the model learns needs to be verified on
data that the model has not seen before.
It is like giving the model an exam or a test.
And the test scores give us a way of estimating how well the model will fare.
Much like we test children's ability to use the knowledge they learn in school
through tests and use the test scores to evaluate and rank their abilities.
So now that we know that we will need some data to
test our models we can either go and collect more data to test them.
Or simply set aside a part of the data that we have already collected for
the purpose of testing.